la france est très en retard en matière
d'énergies renouvelables et le
gouvernement a décidé de produire 20% de
l'électricité grâce aux éoliennes d'ici
à 2010 les projets vont donc se
multipliaient dans tout le pays avec
leur lot de polémiques dans la somme le
village denis basse n'a pas hésité une
seconde
les habitants ont dit oui au moulin à
vent modernes il y en a déjà quatorze
dans la campagne environnante josé blanc
la pierre remy poissonnier cratère la
pièce maîtresse d'un immense légaux 45
tonnes de fibre de verre et de résine
bichonné par une équipe de pros venus de
toute l'europe de la haute précision
pour un montage délicat fixé le bateau
oiseaux à son mât le nez au vent 14
machines au total le premier et unique
parc éolien de la somme s'achève ces
jours ci sous l'oeil des habitants
plutôt fier d'avoir été les premiers à
dire oui au projet c'est pas parce qu'on
avait qu'un petit village qu'il faut pas
évolué au contraire peut-être que ça
servira d'exemple pour d'autres villages
une taxe professionnelle de 80 mille
euros c'est ce que rapporte le parc à la
commune autrement dit 10% de son budget
tombé du ciel cela ne se refuse pas
d'après l'ensemble de la population est
amer convaincu d'avant j'ai mis un
article pour je dirais faire une
comparaison entre les moulins à vent qui
avait chez nous il ya 200 ans et les
éoliennes qui pourrait devenir
existantes actuellement que j'appellerai
les moulins à vent modernes et quand il
a fallu trouver des terrains disponibles
même réaction du côté des agriculteurs
6000 euros de loyer par an et par
machine ça aide surtout quand le blé se
paie moins cher que ça vous rappelle il
ya une vingtaine d'années j'ai en parlé
on avait les poteaux électriques c'est
vrai que vont elles a fallu les subir on
n'était pas indemnisés
c'est vrai que c'était un peu gros quand
même quoi on a choix pour guillou et ont
dit non aujourd'hui ces drôles d'oiseaux
ont du mal à se faire accepter
il faut pourtant moins de bruit et sont
beaucoup plus rentables qu'à leurs
débuts
martel l'installateur français les
hellènes ont évolué extraordinairement
en dix ans une éolienne comme celle que
vous voyez implanté ici remplace 60
éoliennes de l'époque de 1994
ça veut dire que maintenant c'est des
vrais moyens de produire beaucoup
d'électricité
une éolienne à elles seules alimente
2000 foyers en électricité du courant
qui rejoint le réseau national et qui se
vend 8 centimes le kilowatt deux fois
plus que le tarif en vigueur dans la
somme 300 projets sont en attente 50 ont
été refusées en bloc